[Music]
oh
well they won't have to because blake
did it he finally
finally put a ring on gwen's finger but
the question is
who was dragging their feet our source
tells e.t blake was the one to take it
slow in the beginning but recently quote
decided it was time
when did you know gwen was the one for
you
uh it didn't take long it ended up being
the greatest moment of my life blake
saved my life everybody knows that
our source says their simple life
together at blake's oklahoma ranch
during quarantine made him realize the
importance of spending life with the
person you love
i'd love to have you on team one during
last night's episode of the voice there
was no mention of the engagement because
the blind auditions were pre-taped
earlier this summer
but they did get a shout out on screen
didn't you write a song called
i'm just a girl i do she also wrote one
called don't speak
but back to the wedding our source says
the couple is in no rush and gwen has
always spoken about a quote
big traditional wedding with friends and
family
no doubt gwen's three sons kingston zuma
and apollo would play a big role
our source says for now they're going to
see how the pandemic pans out and enjoy
the engagement
[Music]